a record for civil liberties for the
Libertarians
to my mind is very good and even I think
it was the last interview we did with a
libertarian kind of a present said he
would polish the CIA the FBI and the IRS
did you hold those same position yes I
do
because you know most of our history we
didn't didn't have those institutions
the FBI came in during the first world
war and interestingly enough the one
thing that Woodrow Wilson did he used
the FBI to spy on American citizens and
actually arrests them if they disagreed
with his foreign policy about going to
war in Europe and is it an interesting
how recent they used it in the Vietnam
era Democrats used their Republicans
used the FBI to spy on a hundred
different groups in this country
including the churches who disagree with
the policy in Central America it almost
looks like the FBI was designed to spy
on Americans who might be disagreeing
with policy especially the foreign
policy so the FBI although I don't think
I could condemn everything they've ever
done because I'm sure some of the
investigations and investigation of
crime has been beneficial but that could
be accomplished through Justice
Department within our state's we
wouldn't reject that portion of it I
think the FBI has kept and continues to
keep a lot of records on a lot of
individuals the CIA has only been here
since 1947 their record is lousy you
just think of the CIA used by the
Democratic administration to murder diem
and escalate the war in Vietnam here we
have a Republican using the CIA to sell
weapons to the Ayatollah to raise funds
dealing drugs go to Central America
fight wars that have not been approved
by the people or the Congress so we see
the CIA is very very detrimental
skirting the law and here we had Casey
proposing a super CIA he thought there
was too much control over the CIA that
existed that congressmen now
occasionally ask questions and they
don't ask enough so they were talking
about a super CIA the CIA II was used in
a bad policy in Cuba
we think the intelligence-gathering is
permissible to defend this country but
up until 1947 it was done as a military
operation if you needed to know whether
there were troops massing for an
invasion that the CIA ought to know
about the we ought to know get that
information now have that intelligence
but now in this age especially in the
modern age I mean we don't even need to
have somebody over in Europe or in the
Soviet Union we don't even need to send
powers in an airplane every year we have
satellites you can practically watch an
individual walking around on the street
with the technology available so so I
would say even modern technology is a
absolutely moved us into an age where we
ought to become more modern and get away
from this CIA operative snooping around
actually causing a lot more trouble than
good that include all these
interventions and covert actions and
surrogate mercenaries which were using
in camps of America absolutely we would
do away with that but that doesn't mean
that we would complacently say that we
shouldn't have a national defense if
we're concerned about the spread of
communism one of the first things we as
libertarians would do would be to stop
the funding of the Communists you know
we're still sending money to the
Communists increase that under the
Reagan administration is unbelievable
what we've been but we've been doing but
if there is a threat to our national
security
rather than using these secretive
operatives going around and murdering
and picking and choosing our personal
dictators that serve our banking and
business interests it should be done so
through the Congress Congress should
know about it it's the people's money
it's the kids lives that are being dealt
with so therefore it should be open if
our national security is threatened
Congress ought to have a vote on it
never secretly with the power of a
president to wage war that's a very
dangerous thing to happen